from The Daily Mail Budweiser teams up
with Harley Davidson for very manly new
advert as owner of Anheuser-Busch tries
to recover from Bud Light backlash over
marketing campaign with trans influencer
Dylan Mulvaney Let's uh let's show you
how manually mentally you are let's play
the let's play the video you guys ready
yeah
our build with grit and resilience
[Music]
at a time limited edition Budweiser
Harley Davidson cans
for those who give everything to their
craft
there's words for you why why though why
I don't know about you guys but I'm
feeling manlier already limited edition
I'm sold it's almost like parody like
the way they're doing it like the voice
and everything I'm like oh my gosh who's
who's honestly gonna buy this in an
effort to please everyone they've made
everyone hate them but do you want to
buy the can and then put the can on the
wall or something
so bizarre and it's it's funny too
because it's like I wasn't really one
for boycotts and I was kind of like a
like a Budweiser guy when I drank beer
and this is like the first boycott I've
like kind of Taken part of and like it's
been successful
um and it really makes sense why it's
successful is because you know those are
the types of people that are you know
drinking beer or whatever and you know
when you see these other companies like
Nike or whatever they can afford to lose
you know people who pay attention to
politics half the country you know
doesn't really care and they're gonna
say I like you know LeBron James or
whatever I'm gonna buy his shoes but but
like Bud Light or Budweiser it's gotten
like a lot of people's attention I saw
like clay Travis had like the cooler
challenge type thing where he had a
mixture of beer and then uh at the end
of the night he opens it and it's like
full of Bud Light because it was like
those are the only beers that people
didn't take so it's just become so he
bought Bud Light he yeah right I I guess
I I don't know the whole story of where
the sourcing came though yeah you could
have gotten it for free was he doing it
like as a social experiment to see if
people started off that way but I just
realized it he posted on Twitter just
like the cooler uh I don't know if it
was like a cookout or whatever he was at
but but yeah it was like the cooler
before and then after it was like only
Bud Light left this is a desperate
attempt because Memorial Day is here
yeah and so it's also been like a very
slow day also people can probably tell
because everybody's getting ready to
just take off and go on their Memorial
Day three-day holiday or whatever
weekend but uh I I kind of could sense
something like this was going to come
because Memorial Day was is the danger
zone for Bud Light people are going to
be grilling people are going to be
hanging out they're going to go to the
lake and this is when they're like we
need to move product yeah and this was
the best they could do so I got bad news
for you guys though this doesn't make
Budweiser manlier it makes Harley
Davidson gayer
fine like look man like if you are a man
who likes to and have adult relations
with other men and ride motorcycles no I
mean the series like I got no beef like
that's that's totally fine I live your
life you know be happy but but
Budweiser's brand
I can't believe Harley-Davidson was like
let's get in on that
because people are making meme videos
there's a video I saw where a dude goes
to the store and he's like buying beer
and then this other guys grabs a thing
of Bud Light and he goes you're buying
Bud Light and the guy goes well look man
I don't care about the politics I've
always drank Bud Light he's like oh okay
then he grabs a case looks over and the
guy bends down to tie his shoe and then
his pants reveals he's wearing a thong
yeah and then he's like okay and he puts
the Bud Light back and then grabs
something else oh good so it's like but
but my point with mentioning that is
that people are are
Bud Light is a meme now oh yeah it is it
is they're like you cannot save the
brand all you can do is taint anything
else yeah I think I think you're totally
right and I also think that there's
there is the the sense from the average
person that it if they buy Bud Light
they're engaging in politics
you know what I mean it's like they had
most people that want to you know just
go to the bar and have a beer with their
friends or go shoot pool or go to the
game whatever they're actually trying to
avoid politics and if they buy Bud Light
they're going to feel like they're
engaging in it and that's something that
is is not easy to get rid of and it's
definitely something that Bud Light
doesn't or that you know bud doesn't
want and this the Harley-Davidson thing
it's not going to move the needle
because people are still gonna feel like
if I buy bud and support I'm engaging in
politics if I don't buy it
I'm not engaging because there's a bunch
of other beers but if dude buy blood
then I'm saying I support this there's
nothing they can do to salvage the brand
like there's no ad campaign where we're
gonna be like oh now it's okay it's
literally just them coming out and
apologizing but they definitely will not
do that they're going to do something
like this
and Harley-Davidson I mean I I got I
gotta ask is is is is it big is Harley
big are they are they I don't I don't
understand what the point of this is
with bikers yeah still I think so I mean
if you're interested if you're into
motorcycles especially like the cruiser
style I think that Harley's probably
still the name that people are kind of
well when you see a dude in a Harley you
go Pride yeah and then you walk up to
the guys on the bikes and just be like
I'm so happy that you guys can be
together you think this is gonna taint
South Park's already between between
this South Park South Park did that
episode
everybody you know everyone remembers
that South Park episode
the two of them well yeah but I just
meant like predict prediction-wise oh
yeah and then South Park even had that
episode Simpsons did it when I talk
about that I'm just I'm just
I
did the people that marketing people at
Harley Davidson are they unaware think
at all like Target stock is is is
free-falling and you know I wonder if
they did this deal in advance well the
target had to print the cans I was gonna
say it takes time to print but it spins
it's been two months
a year ago that yeah we're gonna do it
this holiday weekend could you imagine
like Harley-Davidson Executives calling
out Budweiser like no no no no no we're
done we don't want to do this and
they're like no you can't get enough
you're here now we got we got you
oh my gosh yeah I got an update on the
the VP or the marketing exact that was
uh they're both still I believe there's
two that they put on leave there's no
updates though no I don't know just Bud
Lights Budweiser is down a bit not as
bad as Bud Light but a bunch of the
brands are down the reason I think that
the uh the reason this this boycott
worked is and this is great because this
is the watershed moment this is like
this is the ignition point is that it's
it's perishable so that means it has to
move from shelves quickly otherwise it
gets trashed that if you get three days
of people not buying something
then immediately they're going to be
like sales report it's down people are
throwing away cans then it's going to
hit the new cycle again and it's going
to stay in the news cycle with Target
it's more difficult yeah with Disney's
more difficult because people could
boycott it for three days and then come
right back you might not even notice or
they could totally boycott it you're not
going to get any news from for three
months until the next quarter when they
do reports and stuff like uh sales sales
reports or subscriber reports Target
might not feel it right away well
Target's got perishable Goods too they
sell groceries yeah but if if 80 of
people keep shopping at Target they're
going to move that product what happened
is Bud light's perishable and people
noticed right away nobody was buying it
stores started to panic and then it hits
the news again wow these stores aren't
selling Bud Light once it gets back in
the news more people start asking why
that causes the news to Ripple and and
the cult and the meme to Ripple then the
stock tanks now we've created the Bud
Light effect which is probably the most
powerful tool when Target faces a
boycott it doesn't matter if it's sales
what matters is shareholders get scared
that they're going to go the same route
as Bud Light and if Bud Light tanked
after everyone said no bud light's great
Anheuser-Busch is going to do great if
it's still Tanked then you're sitting on
Target stock you're going to be like no
I better I better not I better not have
this I'm not giving you any advice I'm
telling you what to do I'm just saying
I'm sure a lot of people were like
whether whether you know or not that
Target stock will go down
why wait like there's no positive news
right yeah so if I'm looking at my stock
portfolio and I've got let's just say
let's do a hundred dollars I'm like the
negative news is not going to make the
stock go up is it it may make the stock
go down I'll sell and hold on to 100
yeah sell the stock hold the cash wait
to see what happens then that triggers a
sell-off the sell-off creates a
self-fulfilling prophecy and then so
anyway back to uh Harley Davidson I'm
wondering if they're gonna get because
someone someone told me this uh the
other day we were talking about it and
we didn't you know I don't know it's
Harley Davidson publicly traded
I do not know I don't know
let's see they are and they're currently
up 0.52 percent they're up uh one point
two six percent in the past five days I
gotta be honest man I would not be
surprised to see Harley Davidson stock
take a hit when this news breaks that
being said the news is breaking on a
Friday yeah holiday weekend too Memorial
Day Weekend everybody's already gone
yeah like I don't even know why we're
here to be a blast we're not going to be
here on Monday but I was like I guess we
have to do something we can hang out you
know okay
um there's you know you were talking
about the Target stock and stuff there's
I saw Clint tweeted this earlier uh from
Liberty lockpod
um more than 60 civil so Civil Society
groups are now demanding that all
businesses cease Twitter ad buys because
musk had the audacity to let Ron
DeSantis announces presidential run on
Twitter uh and it's because of it's
because of the ESG Dei stuff
if you've got
what are ostensibly capitalist
organizations pressuring
other organizations to stop buying ads
because of politics uh I imagine that
the ESG and Dei stuff that incentivize
Target to do the things like having the
pride you know the pride stuff every
year I feel like that is gonna be I feel
like people are going to start taking
notice of that taking notice of the ESG
stuff because it's it's already
something that you hear kind of rumbling
I saw something on CNBC they were doing
a basically a hit on it and And
discussing the benefits
um and I think that that could be
something really really good for the the
right basically because it's better than
boycotting one company yeah it gets
people to focus on what is basically
social engineering of a of the
capitalist system you know and that has
been such an effective way to get
compliance from corporations and stuff
like that and that's I honestly I think
the the most important thing to to focus
on if you're looking at boycotts or
whatever you want to hit companies in
the pocketbook look for companies that
are are making uh ESG and Dei
commitments thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time